So the answer's 20. And here's why. So
initially, we've created the name hours, and assigned it
the value 9. So, I was, will refer to the number, 9. That's what we have after
the first assignment statement. For the second assignment
statement, first we evaluate the right side. And that
says hours plus 1. That will produce, 10, heading 1 to 9. And now we assign that
new value to hours. So that'll change what
the name hours refers to. Now ours will ref,
refer to the, number 10. Then we do
a multiplication. The third assignment statement, has hours on
the right-side, hours times 2. So that will
evaluate to, the value hours refers to which is
10, times 2, so we get 20. And then
we get assignment, that will change the value of
hours to now refer to 20. So, at the
end of these statements, the value of hours is 20.